[Musique]
bon le déjeuner c'est ça
se passe bien monsieur Deluxe
ça va c'est super regardez il y a la
réalisatrice qui arrive là-bas bonjour
attention
et bon appétit bien sûr
[Rires]
[Musique]
ah merci
ma fille j'en peux plus j'avais plus moi
je dis une recette incroyable à vous
partager si vous écoutez ce matin sur
Virgin Radio d'ailleurs vous pouvez la
faire au petit déj hein c'est le fromage
avec du nutella donc en fait je parsème
du fromage fondu sur une tartine vous
faites chauffer au micro-ondes environ
20 secondes et après vous Saussez dans
du Nutella ah oui c'est très bon c'est
riche en calcium riche en fruits secs
voilà c'est un petit déjeuner équilibré
je vous propose maintenant sur le
général
qui peuvent le faire
ça vient de tomber j'ai l'honneur de
vous annoncer que je suis nominé dans la
catégorie artiste francophone de l'année
haut et Notger Music Awards et il
s'avère que j'en ai déjà un pour la
révélation francophone de l'année et
c'était en 2012 or nous sommes en 2022
coïncidence je ne pense pas alors voter
pour moi
que ben voilà à partir d'aujourd'hui
vous allez me retrouver plus souvent
parce que
j'étais un peu fragile et j'ai eu
beaucoup souffert de
mauvais commentaires sur mes réseaux qui
deviennent le plus en plus virulent mais
maintenant
il faut aussi que je pense à ce qui me
soutiennent depuis des années
et qui ont fait son savoir
je prends beaucoup soufflé dans beaucoup
de moments